ciao guglielmo una mia fissazione del
pianto ma test in una teglia per
mandarvi un messaggio visto che gli
ammorbidenti di avere detto che la fissa
per le teche e che avevo ordinati
riscatto nodi che vediamo viventi che è
sicuramente da quanti scricciolo porterà
sicuramente alla tomba perché si
ammorbidisce stata aperta per quanto già
informato ciao ragazzi bentornati a una
nuova puntata di vita buttata il tema
della puntata di oggi credo che sia uno
dei miei preferiti perché manie e
ossessioni della puntata di oggi ha
deciso di riportare qui all'interno
degli studios di casa mia forse il vero
protagonista di questa rubrica che è
rullo di tamburi che mio fratello enrico
enrico benvenuto boss allora il rito lo
sai che sei tipo la stella di questa
breve a persone con human e non voglio
alimentare va bene alla lei allora
all'atroce di calcio ma dopo varie
ricerche ho scoperto che la mia fobia di
chiamata rito fobia dei fondi a chi è lo
spunto è la scuola sta volgendo libro di
scienze di una perfezione ad alta voce e
esce da questa immagine mi interessavo
leggendo ad alta voce con andrea casile
va a balbettare apocalittica davanti a
tutto
un'immagine con quattro buchi e morto in
pratica in pratica se qualcuno mi
affatico una carezza sulla guancia ma sa
che c'è un'altra volta perché l'altra
volta siamo cinema rionale se ti ha
fatto un culo proprio stock a me ne vado
contro uno spigolo il colpo al ginocchio
del ginocchio
sapevo di che cosa ma come fa sbatte il
mignolo del piede il classico migliorino
e che cazzo è tutta la sofferenza che
hanno riguardo quando faccio doccia
perché di potere
chiti volte
atrimenti so che in te lo faccio non mi
internata tutta colpa di pechino
rimane anche con teheran che allora
situazioni maria cerio allora devo
dormire con la tapparella alzata di
almeno una spanna
poi se non ho la porta completamente
chiesa della camera deve essere
totalmente aperta perché se no non posso
dormire perché penso che qualcuno
facciamo miracoli quando vedo qualcuno
che lo fa leggete qualità porta bartali
cadenti non vive secondo mettono la
forchetta del tratto la moglianese mio
amico invece che chiude tutte le porte
tipo la notte no ma se c'è un assassino
è più lucide tutto così che si rende
conto se verdi è negativa aperta la
donna abita da solo no stavamo bene il
film era un'opera bisogna chiuderla
follie alleati con lo sgabuzzino
voi pensate che mio fratello enrico sia
semplicemente un sorridente ragazzo non
mi crederanno fissato ragazzi con col
fatto che tutto sia sporco sì possiamo
dirlo di ho le mie posate da scout la
scout quelle tutele pieghevoli e usa
perché non può usare
domani perché tutto sporco e i miei
piatti bisogna argan di plastica i miei
bicchieri
poi però il suo letto
c'è invece alimenta relazione alla
protesta e la merda piatti il
dentifricio scarto la sempre la prima
parte estremi dentifricio da qualche
colpetto per farlo scendere da solo non
lo devi toccare c'erano che si rifà o no
e poi vuoi usare però papa potrebbe
parcheggiare la nostra macchina la
versione russa fa paura
non so perché da dove sia partito da
questa calda ma praticamente quando
conosco qualcuno gli chiedo di fare la
foto alla propria carta d'identità dove
c'è la foto punto identificativa è una
cartella sul telefono non era partito
più di cinquanta foto di carta
d'identità tutte le persone che come so
che a caso al lavoro con e non so perché
ma mi fa ridere guardare le loro facce
sulle nuove cartine tanto la forza della
cantina perché come ha fatto paura la
realizzazione che quando la dalle
macchinette al lavoro o comunque pazzia
di altro posto
prendo solamente le cose con numero pari
delle cose che voglio non ci sono perché
dovevo pari di sonno e se non fa un
numero pari non le prendo pioggia da
quante volte capita che mi voglio
prendere tweet è il numero di file atom
di parete alla fine non lo vendo mai
immaginare di cose se siete quella sede
23 in un bagno pubblico in spagna e
quindi ora ogni volta in un bagno
pubblico
io apro la porta a porta ha chiuso la
serratura a chiave alla linea pro per
vedere che si apra chiuso la porta ma ci
dà chiave in allegato lo apro la porta
fino alla volta lasci la chiave e per
evitare una piccina mia mi ha raccontato
che se avesse pronunciato una parola
nello stesso esatto momento in cui
un'altra persona la pronunciava io posso
persone ci siamo sposati a meno che non
fosse toccata al naso ma cos'è questa
quella che insomma tutto niente tanto
che uno spettacolo scolastico in cui
erano il coro ho passato un'ora e mezza
a cantare col dito sul naso perché non
volevo scollare gli altri 12 nei
compagni
ovviamente cantavano ai miei stesse cose
stesse lotto momento nonostante i 19
anni di vita e niente ti faccio tanti
complimenti
[Musica]
[Risate]
una mia mania è che io metto le
forchette al 3 coltelli e cucchiai
devono stare lontano dai coltelli
perché la mia mania è che il cucchiaio
il bastardo dalla editrice e quindi
rovinare il matrimonio fra la forchetta
e coltello
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video io ringrazio la star di
questa rubrica mio fratello enrico
ma soprattutto ringrazio voi ma
soprattutto ringrazio voi ma soprattutto
l'interazione di via perché rimandato
ogni volta un sacco di messaggi e sempre
un piacere leggerli io vi diamo
appuntamento al prossimo video è fino ad
allora ciao arrivo che cosa da dire
sulle persone niente raggiungere di
ottenere così è [ __ ] proporre a parlare
del inclusiva mai nera